[Music]
hello and welcome to our session on
Google's top HPC best practices for
deploying and managing the most
demanding workloads my name is Wyatt
Gorman and I'm the high performance
Computing Solutions manager at Google
Cloud
during this talk we will share HPC best
practices by describing our scalable HPC
platform and infrastructure available
within Google Cloud as well as the
solutions available from Google and our
partners to simplify running your
preferred HPC applications job
schedulers and storage systems and more
throughout the talk you'll also hear
about how some of our HPC customers are
benefiting from expanding their
environments to include Google Cloud
let me start by introducing Google
Cloud's platform and our vision and
strategy for high performance computing
when we think about how we're making
Google Cloud a great place for people to
run their HPC workloads we think about
things in terms of four key pillars
first we've prioritized making Google
Cloud fast and affordable bringing to
the platform the latest and greatest HPC
technology in areas like CPUs and gpus
and Building Technology that will work
well for HPC specific things like MPI
scalability
is incompatible focuses on making our
Cloud HPC platform as HPC capable and is
easy to use for newcomers to HPC as it
is for HPC gurus with Cloud
certifications and furthermore we want
to make our platform compatible with and
well supported by the HPC partners that
we all work with that leads to partner
preferred where we work to ensure a
broad network of supported software
partners and system integrators to
ensure our customers can easily
Implement their HPC workloads on Google
cloud and we make sure that we bring our
HPC users the best of Google by engaging
industry experts to help customers
modernize into the cloud and by making
use of things like Google's Global
Network to support HPC users who are
collaborating around the world let's
take a look at our HPC platform and dive
into the infrastructure Solutions and
best practices behind it
our HPC platform consists of three
layers in yellow with our Cloud
infrastructure at the base including
compute Network and storage we'll dive
into those different areas and options
and best practices for those core
building blocks in a bit I want to talk
about GK in this talk at a time but I'd
encourage you to go watch the GK talk on
batch workloads where one of our major
HPC customers in the energy industry
we'll share how they're running their
seismic exploration workloads on Google
Cloud
above infrastructure we have the
development and deployment layers which
include our partner Integrations for
essential components like job scheduler
storage or a complete HBC platform and
you'll also find some of our core
solution components like our HPC toolkit
our HPC VM images and batch that allow
users to deploy and manage HPC
environments and workloads easily let's
look at the infrastructure building
blocks before we continue to build on
that with our partners and solutions
looking at our HPC infrastructure most
people think of three key components
when they think of infrastructure in
high performance Computing that's
compute storage and network let's dive
into each of these areas to see what's
available for HPC users what best
practices we recommend and how our
customers have benefited from running
their HPC workloads on Google Cloud
looking first at compute Google offers a
wide variety of VM families to support
all workloads and choosing the right VM
type for your workload is an important
best practice on the left we have our
general purpose VMS where those include
some of our lower performing
cost-efficient VM types like the E2
which works well for scale out workloads
like web hosting and our workload
optimized VM families on the right
complement those those include some of
our VM families like HPC like the C
Series with our HPC specific
capabilities as well as the a series you
might be wondering what makes HPC VMS
different than general purpose VMS and
what improvements those differences make
for HPC workloads
well HPC VMS have several key
differences that make them perform well
for HPC workloads today first is the
choice of hardware and features that
goes into the VM we choose High clock
speed and well-balanced CPU types high
bandwidth memory high performance gpus
and we focus on how we design the system
very carefully to support compute
intensive and I O intensive workloads
that means these VMS also support
features like disabling smt also known
as Intel hyper threading for Optimal
Performance where SNT is not preferred
next is virtual pneumo which provides a
direct mapping of host CPU to the guest
CPU giving your guest operating system a
view of the way it's truly laid out on
the physical host machine allowing for
improved memory management and CPU
pinning it's also ensures socket
isolation and other optimized CPU
scheduling
third is our support for placement
policies which include improves Network
latency and I'll share more about and
and later slide
finally there are a number of network
optimizations which include 100 gigabit
per second VM throughput 9 kmtus an
improved virtual Nic driver and tunings
which optimize HPC performance
so what do these differences make in
terms of HPC performance in the real
world well if you take our latest c2dvm
family as an example we've seen a 66
performance Improvement when comparing
it against the n2dvm which is our
general purpose VM type or the previous
generation of AMD epic CPU and without
the same kind of HPC optimizations
those material differences translate to
a real world Improvement in cost and
time to resolve for our customers
airshaper is one example of a customer
that's seen those improvements as well
and they've seen a 50 Improvement in
costs and a 30 reduction in simulation
times when compared to the previous
generation of VMS which is three times
faster than their on-premises
environment
in addition to CPU VM types like the
c2dvm family we also have multiple GPU
VM families and GPU types supported
through VM families like our H2 VM
Family hvms Support up to 16 Nvidia a100
gpus per VM they're backed by Intel
Cascade like CPUs similar to the high
performance C2 VM family this
configuration provides customers like
the Allen Institute for AI a 4X
performance improvement over their
existing systems without any major code
changes
bulk API is an important best practice
for everyone running HPC at large scales
as well the bulk API combines two key
capabilities to improve the time to
deploy large-scale HPC clusters first is
the ability to deploy up to a thousand
identical instances with a single API
call that dramatically reduces the time
spent sending individual API calls for
hvm creation and second is regional
deployment rather than zonal deployment
which searches for capacity for you and
adds flexibility to your HPC deployments
to avoid stockouts and it get your HPC
VMS deployed faster
with these features it bulk API can
speed up large scale instance deployment
by up to 500 in our testing
choosing the right storage for your
workload is an important best practice
as well and Google has a variety of HPC
storage options to fit your needs Google
offers managed services for object block
and file storage and is partnered with
leading storage providers to support
their file storage solutions including a
number of parallel file system offerings
including luster Spectrum scale gpfs
most recently Intel deos to support your
most demanding scratch storage
requirements
and we know that storage is not one size
fits all and that HPC clusters achieved
the best performance reliability and
cost Effectiveness by combining storage
systems in a hierarchy of storage and
that's why we built the storage transfer
service to support customers who need to
move data from on-premises into the
cloud and between their multiple
distributed storage systems with storage
transfer service you can use a Google
service to manage high performance data
movement for you and when combined with
the burst buffer capabilities in our
partner scheduler offerings it becomes a
powerful tool to easily and free and
post stage data as part of your overall
HPC workflow
Google's networking is the third key
infrastructure component that makes up
the Google HPC infrastructure and there
are a large number of best practices
that should be used to achieve the best
possible HPC application performance in
terms of networking Google's HPC VMS can
be configured with tr1 bandwidth which
enables up to 100 gigabit per second and
two in between VMS combine that with our
predictable low latency and you already
have a very capable HPC system for many
workloads but when you add on the types
of tunings and optimizations that are
available on Google Cloud through our
HPC VM image and things like our new
Google Virtual Nic or 9kmtus and
placement policies you can achieve an
extraordinary type of performance
placement policies are a new feature for
Google customers and using placement
policies is an important HPC best
practice placement policies allow users
to manage their HPC VMS according to
network topology and there are two types
Compact and Spread spread is used for
aha purposes and it isn't really
interesting for most HPC use cases but
compact is specifically built for and
supported on HPC VM families
it's designed to minimize Network Hops
and therefore minimize latency between
VMS which can dramatically improve
performance for tightly coupled
workloads
costs can be an important consideration
when moving to and running workloads in
the cloud and placement policies can now
produce the total runtime of a workload
which is a great way of reducing the
total cost of workload but there are
also a few key best practices you should
also follow when minimizing the cost of
your HPC workloads one is to consider
using custom machine types when possible
that allows users to Define their HPC uh
their their own instance profile outside
the bounds of the standard instance
profiles like a 4 8 or 16 core VM and to
set something like a 10 core VM with 10
gigabytes of RAM or that includes a GPU
and so on custom machine types can
reduce the cost of running a workload by
up to 19 so take advantage of them when
you can committed use discounts and
other discounting programs are also
available and you should talk to your
Google rep about what kind of discounts
and credit programs are available for
you finally spot VMS or your own are our
replacement
for uh preemptable VMS they could be up
to 91 cheaper than a standard instance
and there's no set time limit like with
preemptable VMS which makes them even
better for HPC workloads when you're
using spot VMS we recommend focusing on
loosely coupled workloads checkpointed
jobs and MPI jobs with around eight
nodes in a job or less to minimize the
potential for impact from node
preemption
so what kind of real world results are
our customers seeing from our HPC
infrastructure well epfl Swiss plasma
center is one of our HPC users and
they're simulating chocolate Mac Fusion
reactors on Google Cloud they've not
only seen that it's easy to spin up HPC
clusters in Google Cloud but that those
clusters are extremely performant and
are delivering to them a 33x speed up
for their tokamax simulation with a
nearly perfect scaling efficiency of
their workload up to 32 nodes in a
Google Cloud HPC platform
so the infrastructure components are the
essential building blocks but what
methods are available for you to put
together an HPC environment in the cloud
there are a few key ways
take the analogy of a cake for a moment
there are essentially three ways to get
a cake one is to bake a cake from
scratch go out and get the individual
ingredients and assemble the ingredients
into a cake yourself and that's our
first option you go out you get the
individual pieces and partner solutions
to bake your own cake create your own
HPC cluster from scratch and that's how
we historically recommended people build
their HPC environments on Google Cloud
as well with the support of our partner
organizations and partner Professional
Services however today there are two new
options the second option is to go out
and buy a boxed cake mix from the store
this is a much easier option because
most of the ingredients are already
included for you and you just need to
follow the instructions do some assembly
and maybe a little bit of customization
with a dash of vanilla or something and
in a very short time you can have a cake
that's the cloud HPC toolkit it's a
flexible tool kit designed to take all
the individual ingredients the
individual solutions from Google and its
partners and assemble them together for
you in a way that's easy for you to
configure and assemble without needing
to buy each ingredient separately and
learn how to assemble them
and it has HPC Google's HPC best
practices built in for you and all of
our HPC experience so you don't have to
work hard to ensure a good performance
the last option in how to get your cake
is to go to a bakery and buy a cake
that's already made that's the batch
path where you can use our Cloud native
manage batch service to deploy your
workloads directly to Google Cloud it's
supported by the cloud HPC toolkit and
despite not necessarily having as many
features as some of our partner
scheduler Solutions it's a quick and
easy way to get started running HPC on
Google Cloud for users who are just
starting and for power users alike
let's take a better look at the
solutions available for each method of
implementation
regardless of how you're building your
HPC environment you'll want to ensure
you're building on the HPC VM image this
is a turnkey Centos 7 based image that
launches with all the HPC best practices
for MPI performance including OS tunings
optimizations and recommendations it's
easy to deploy and it already is built
into our partner offerings and the cloud
HPC toolkit so it's ready out of the box
the benefits of using the HPC VM image
are significant as well where we've seen
an almost a 25 reduction in runtime of
the lsdyna 3 car crash model across
eight VMS compared to a vanilla Centos
image
deploying your HPC environment with the
hpcvm image is a simple best practice
that everyone should take advantage of
when baking your cake from scratch along
with the HPC VM image you would choose
your preferred scheduler and storage
platforms from our supported Partners
combine their code with your application
and possibly bring in a systems
integrator to help deploy and manage the
HPC environment
this process requires pretty significant
HPC expertise as well as time spent
learning how each piece is cloud
integration operates how the components
work together and how to manage them
long term luckily though the HPC the
cloud HPC toolkit is ready and there to
simplify this process for you
the cloud HPC toolkit is a modular
toolkit written in terraform and it's
designed to make it easy to deploy a
repeatable turnkey HPC environments with
Google Cloud's HPC best practices all
built in the toolkit consists of three
key components first blueprint which is
a yaml based architecture of what your
specifications for your HPC environment
should be built to and These Blueprints
can be specific to a workload they could
be general purpose or they can be
focused on a partner solution for
example the toolkit comes with several
example and Community provided
Blueprints and users can customize These
Blueprints to meet their needs
blueprints reference modules then that
the toolkit supports and these modules
break down into several types like
scheduler and storage the modules are
then deployed onto our HPC
infrastructure let's take a look at how
these pieces come together and how the
toolkit Works to deploy your environment
when a user builds a blueprint they
reference HPC modules the modules are
scripts that can be imported for public
sources like GitHub or can be built by a
user for public and private use these
modules are configured in the blueprint
through a set of variables in each
module and the modules come together to
Define all the components of an HPC
environment including the network
storage schedule or compute resources
and so on the blueprint is then fed into
the ghpc engine which will import the
HPC module code as needed and build a
deployment folder with the scripts
needed to deploy the complete HPC
environment as defined in the blueprint
the deployment folder can then be used
to directly deploy the HPC environment
into the cloud or it can be modified
packaged or distributed as needed that
gives admins flexibility and
repeatability by allowing them to zip up
and archive the deployment that's used
for an experiment to be used to repeat
the experiments in the future or it can
be sent to an individual user to allow
them to deploy and manage their own HPC
environment in their own project and so
on the HPC environment deploys it's
created with all the HPC best practices
and has security built in and integrates
with the best of Google like Cloud
monitoring blogging and budgeting to
allow users to Monitor and manage their
HPC environments really easily
an impact of using the toolkit versus
do-it-yourself is pretty clear the
toolkit you could a user can write 59
lines of blueprint code that would
translate to thirteen thousand five
hundred lines of total deployed code and
that dramatically reduces the time that
someone needs to configure and deploy a
complete HPC environment and make the
job it makes the job of managing the HPC
environment that much easier
our partners are already seeing a
tremendous benefit by using and
supporting the HPC toolkit and nag says
they can now stand up a complete HPC
cluster in Google cloud in minutes and
AMD has seen a significant reduction in
the complexity of deploying HPC
workloads in the cloud and improvements
in Automation and error mitigation
simplifying our users experiences of
moving their HPC into the cloud will
improve everybody's ability to do more
science which is really the collective
goal of the HPC community
finally the batch service is an awesome
new managed service for natively
scheduling and executing best jobs at
scale on Google Cloud resources and it's
a cloud native job scheduler built from
the ground up for Google cloud and it's
a powerful tool for anyone from people
looking to just get started running
their workloads on Google Cloud to large
customers building their own custom HPC
platforms and are moving away from
traditional job schedulers maybe well it
doesn't support all of the features you
might find in our established HPC job
scheduler Partners it does support key
scheduling features like job priorities
task retries task timeouts and supports
both Loosely and tightly coupled
workloads including MPI workloads batch
runs on Google Cloud compute engine
today and supports things like spot VMS
and custom machine types like we talked
about to help optimize your costs and we
partnered with several phpc Partners
especially Life Sciences Partners to
bring batch support directly to the
applications that users are familiar
with with Partners like nextflow
and customers are already starting to
see the benefits locomation is a
autonomous Trucking Company who runs
several of their most challenging
workloads on Google cloud and adopted
batch is a new tool to improve their
productivity and they found that they
were able to reduce the time it took for
them to get insights out of their large
data sets by 80 which is a massive
Improvement that allows them to move
faster towards their goal of making
Freight Trucking safer and more
efficient
so throughout our session I've
highlighted several HPC best practices
for you to keep in mind as you start out
or continue on your journey into the
clouds first is choosing the right VM
type make sure you choose an HPC VM type
that matches your HPC workloads and take
advantage of the specific HP CVM
features be sure to use the bulk API
when deploying your HP cvms to speed up
your VM deployment choose the right
storage and don't be afraid to mix
storage types data movement is simple
with the storage transfer service use
the HPC VM networks features like the
9kmtu 100 gigabit per second networking
and best practices to optimize your
network performance especially for MPI
workloads compact placement policies are
a key networking feature that can mean a
big difference in VM to VM performance
and you should reduce your costs using
custom machine types and spot VMS as
well always deploy these Phantoms using
the HPC VM image which comes with our
HPC best practices for MPI built in and
use the cloud HPC toolkit to build the
spoke HPC environments to implements all
our HPC best practices out of the box or
if you're looking for a simpler way to
deploy your HPC workloads try the batch
service for a simple fully managed HPC
scheduler
thank you all so much for your time so
just let us know if we can help you
expand your HPC environment to include
Google Cloud I hope you enjoy the rest
of the next 22.
foreign